thanks yeah thanks for inviting
me Denise and Stefan who is not here um
so I have a rather funky title right so
the rise of uh of tractable circuit from
cryptography to continuous generative
models actually to disguise that uh it's
actually like a more honest title would
be uh some nice work I did recently with
circuits so actually it would be more
honest title
and uh so I promised Dennis to not
overstretch like the Star Wars reference
here so like just here the force is
strong in tractable circuits essentially
I want to motivate like kind of like why
I find them interesting so when I
started uh my PhD I was working with
Basin networks and had some great ideas
like hey we can learn the Basin Network
by just constructing a big bigger back a
bigger Bas Network and like learn the
parameters there and my my supervisor
was like oh that's it's a funky idea but
like you won't be able to do inference
in that and like craps like actually
back then I didn't really understand
what we're actually really doing here
and I also like new networks and I
thought well why aren't we like just
learning that with a new network after
all it's just a function right with
operational semantics if you may
uh uh so we had some fun
yesterday uh and essentially I was like
always for the look or like looking out
for something which is between these
graphical models like probabilistic
machine learning or like probabilistic
models and your networks and 2012 I
actually learned to know about some
product networks which are essentially
like a special case of these
probabilistic circuits so in the nutal
what are probabilistic circuits they are
representations of high dimensional
probability
distributions
so probability distributions and in some
sense like
um yeah I had also to reflect during my
PhD what why is probability so important
in a nutshell and I think this is really
my big uh working hypothesis and
therefore I'm in in probabilistic I'm a
probabilistic machine learner
essentially probability in a notless
optimal and consistent reasoning under
uncertainty and I don't know what AI is
and none of you really do but uh uh so
having like this feature optimal and
consistent reasoning under uncertainty
is that kind of like uh must have in AI
so it's about halfway to AI to uh to to
stretch it a bit uh and like the cool
thing is well this is cool but like also
hard and but however as soon as you have
a probabilistic circuit essentially like
many of the inference scenarios you are
interested in are actually tractable so
you can do exact probabilistic
reasoning therefore probabilistic
circuits the force is strong in
probabilistic circuits what is also nice
is that they really play well with logic
circuits and so in my perspective so uh
probability is actually just like a
generalization of logic the advantage of
logic is in in my perspective you can
talk logic to humans and sometimes this
hard logic structure makes inferences
easier than if you do like fully-fledged
probabilistic uh inference anyhow
probabilistic inference is like actually
like well generalizes to a certain
extent like logical reasoning and the
third thing which I also mentioned
yesterday is like they also play well
together with neural networks right so
like if you have a circuit essentially
it's a connectionist model so you can
actually plug that into neural networks
or can plug neural networks into
circuits and we've done actually both of
that to in various uh modifications
um all right so what is a probabilistic
shortly so like um so I'm really in a
luxury here that I don't need to really
explain decomposability smoothness
structure decomposability determinism
it's really the same thing yeah so like
probably now all of you know this
properties it's really uh exactly the
same things right so like smoothness
means uh right so like essential
probabilistic circuit has three units
leaves uh the inputs uh sum nodes well
these guys here and product noes well
these guys smoothness means like the
inputs of sums they all look at the same
uh random variables the composability
means inputs to products look at
disjoint sets of random variables uh you
know structure the composability all the
products in with the same scope with the
same variable scope factorized the same
way and determinism at most one input to
each sum node is nonzero yeah for each
possible input and really what this is
is like really like kind of uh if you
are familiar with gaus and mixure models
is like just like a deep generalization
of that right so like uh so here we have
maybe a random Vector X and maybe we
have split it in three blocks and here
we spend like maybe a few distributions
just modeling this part here we have a
few distributions just modeling this
part here a few distributions just
modeling this part and this can be like
gaussian but really you not restricted
in what distributions or densities or
probability Mass functions you want to
use here you can even use intractable
ones and I also have done that I've
plugged in V here but if you plug in
something tractable which means where
you can marginalize maximize and what
what not then the whole thing will
essentially inherit checkability yeah
not surprising uh so products are really
just like well together with the
composability this just means well I am
a factorized distribution I am a
distribution over U and u and v and
while I factorizing these two guys so
like really just vanilla probab
factorization of probability
distributions which means actually like
a local Independence and uh smoothness
together in some notes essentially means
well I'm just like a mixture
distribution right so like gin mixtures
a convex combination of densities is
again a density and really so like this
guy is a density is a mixture of these
three distributions this is also mixture
of the same distributions but maybe with
different weights by the way I don't
never draw the weights here on the edges
but essentially they exist right so like
you take a convex combination of these
inputs that's a mixture really you just
build up like deep structured mixture
models in that way
yeah so that's in a not what
probabilistic circuits are and Antonio
was like uh like um asking me to explain
like what is the connection to logic
circuits and the best thing to do is
like actually a meme right so like
what's the difference between logic
circuits and probabilistic circuits so
corporate needs to find out the
difference between this picture and this
picture they are the same picture really
so if you're working with logic circuits
right so like DEC composable and smooth
and whatnot it's really easy to really
convert that into probabilistic circuit
just to replace or gates with sums with
weighted sums yeah convex sums and gates
with products and instead of literals
you take probability densities down
there yeah that automatically allows you
to convert um uh logic circuits to
probabilistic circuits and people can
write papers about that like STDs to to
psds right so like in retrospect is like
a cheap trick but essentially you can do
that essentially with any logic circuit
and the cool thing is essentially like
this still stays compatible in some way
right so like uh you can mix
probabilistic circuits with logic
circuits right uh inference in PCS right
so like um if you're like more like a
database person or or like logic person
well what what means inference in
probability well as as in logics or in
databases well we want we're interested
in queries and we build up complex
queries by concat or like by by by
simpler queries or Primitives right and
smooth the compossibility essentially
allows you to do marginalization so
Computing High dimensional integrals or
high dimensional sums over your
distribution and conditioning which you
really just is like using that as a sub
protein and the most General thing is
like really sum over everything compute
the partition function therefore
essentially in in probabilistic
inference if you can pick only one
people people would proba probably pick
this one so like it's essentially like
some people even um restrict or like
would see marginalization being able to
sum or integrate over your function as
syn synonymous to performing
probabilistic inference in any basan
model right so like if a prior over
whatnot and you have a likelihood and
you want to compute the posterior over
parameters or other unobserved stuff in
in essence you're just solving a big
integral uh there so like a big
interactable integral so ation of PhD
students actually have just like done
that and like tried to approximate that
yeah so marginalization conditioning
determinism also allows it the
maximization so like it's nice like
conditioning means I inject evidence
about something you update your beliefs
and then you want to get like the most
likely configuration so yo Chang was
yesterday doing that right was actually
telling you like uh how to first
marginalize and then maximize well
unfortunately that's like something
intractable and therefore y came up with
a good iterative uh way to actually find
the global maximum structure the
compossibility or compatibility allows
circuit multiplication so the usual
tricks apply
here yeah so like maybe just to
illustrate well
marginalization so say we have this
circuit and we want to get rid of one of
one variable M which is contained in U
and allow me right right so the output
of this circuit essentially like the
density over this whole random Vector X
and he wants now to get rid of this much
of this one variable M so that's
essentially the
uh of marginalization get rid of
something account for this right so
allow me to write this as like a little
integral here at the sum note then I see
well cool integral and sum commutes so I
can pull the integral down to products
right so now this an integral only over
m m only appears here and not here you
see like here m is not contained here so
essentially you can distribute products
right and essentially long story short
is if you want to have this High uh if
you want to integrate one variable out
of here essentially you can integrate it
out of here and leave the rest of of
that unchanged which just means replace
these guys with the marginal where you
marginalize m out here and it's like a
trivial operation for example in Gauss
but all so essentially when you assume
that you can actually do this here
therefore like uh the whole circuit
inherits like this marginalization yeah
so like this core routine of
marginalization you can do ex Scott yeah
yeah so I there's some extreme
independency here though right there are
things that you can't represent right
and and because of that you can exploit
the structure right but you know almost
it looks like you lose Co varience right
looks like very I mean oh okay okay okay
okay okay no right right right right
right right so uh um I actually started
right so like
um I've never seen a person no matter
how smart and you're extremely smart
person uh who's like has like really
realized this automatically yeah they
assume Independence right so that's what
you mean right so like there's an
independent distribution
but the point is like if you have like a
mixture of independent distribution
that's not independent anymore so yeah I
me so everything everything's a mixture
of Gans we're happy so essentially you
know like you have Universal
approximation if you take mixtures of
gaussin even if they're fully uh
factorized this wouldn't be possible if
this was not true right ENT like the
picture I always draw is like let's draw
a gaussian right like if the the
likelihood lines are like XIs aligned
then this means Independence so I have
one gaussian this guy assumes
Independence because it's XIs aligned
this one assumes Independence a mixture
has
correlation so it's it's uh actually
What's Happening Here is like that each
of these Su nodes here is a discrete
random variable like in GA in gausin
mixture models and like conditioned on
this right so like this actually lat
variable with three states right so this
guy randomly picks one of its inputs
maybe then you go here this guy picks
one of of its inputs and so on so
essentially it's a hierarchy of discrete
latent variables and conditioned on that
every it becomes independent but if you
marginalize the C's right so then
essentially everything becomes dependent
but right so like it's a conditional
Independence actually right so
conditioning on all the decisions up
there this is like independent yeah yeah
I I'm just I'm just wondering you know
for case is this going to be a good
approximate representation right I mean
I know people love meur right so uh I
think for many many cases it is right
where is it insufficiency well uh I mean
it depends a lot on on the actual
structure right so like structure is key
you can also try to come up with like an
over parameterized structure but um so
if you're familiar for example I mean
like in principle this is like uh even
complete factorization works if you have
sufficiently many latent States
essentially def theorem essent in
principle but you're right it is
important and like messing up your
structure will uh yeah not not work too
well all
right right okay okay we can marginal
marginalize and now let's um let me
advertise some cool work uh by by this
guy and he and Antonio from last and
some other guys uh from from last year's
newps so actually what you fun you can
have with circuits and like uh so like
they they came up with like this really
nice example so figure you have like
this well this uh maps from video games
and you want to predict like the
shortest path right and if you do that
with deep learning uh you would send it
through a new network a convolution new
network and then you'd say oh I have
like one output for each tile here and
essentially if there is a path segment
then I put output one otherwise zero
just like binary structured output
prediction yes like if image in binary
uh output prediction and now you start
train your rest atet 18 or what not with
a thousand and a million samples and all
of them contain path right so like you
have labeled you have labeled this
shortest path and the the rest net
essentially like optimizes its loss
right and then you ask it a new image a
test image and then it tells you
essentially like uh well this prediction
right so like one one one one onea here
and like zeros everywhere else which
essentially like a path which means oh
jump here then jump here jump over here
then jump here because like Crossing m
is like expensive yeah so essentially
what the new network did is like kind of
get the right uh gist but it it just
didn't realize what a path really is
right and uh so why not tell tell the
newal network right so like um
essentially it's the the task is pretty
simple you have like this images input
you have structured output object so
this is not a path right so like if you
don't tell the new network that it
should output a path it won't recognize
this automatically and essentially it's
like uh you know chat GPT is great right
and essentially like the big deep
learning lie is that with more with
enough data you will fix this maybe but
how much samples do you really need to
all the samples were a correct path how
many do you need to really show them
that the newal network understands
really the concept of path without
making a single mistake and the idea
these guys had and and actually it's a
really nice and simple idea so like from
from circuit perspective it's like kind
of obvious from Deep learning
perspective is mind-blowing so
essentially like we can teach now a Neal
network uh what a path is right so
essentially here's the structure so like
here they have the Deep neural network
that goes into a probabilistic circuit
which is kind of a structured
distribution of pit patterns here which
may violate this path right but on the
other hand it's uh relatively simple to
um to express what a path is in CNF take
that to a compiler and this gives you
some uh um STD so some uh decomposable
and deterministic non- negative
indication form and from from machine
learning perspective this is just like
well for any path right so like this y
here so like any bit pattern which is
not a path this will output zero so
doesn't violate the constraint and
otherwise one it's really just a binary
mask right and you want to take that and
multiply it on the output uh of of your
neural network essentially you just like
if it outputs a non paath you say well
no zero if it outputs a path then you
say well the a probability of a path and
if it is a path you just leave it
through right so it just switch off all
invalid solutions by taking this product
well this was a distribution over all
bit patterns now if clamped something of
that to zero that's not a distribution
anymore you want to renormalize that and
the cool thing is well this is a circuit
circuit you can still marginalize get
the partition function bum you divide
therefore you have now a distribution
over valid path given this input image
yeah and you train that with maximum
likelihood nice simple idea beautiful
right so and essentially um well you can
guarantee that that now that you network
just predicts like this um correct
Solutions yeah correct path
yeah any deta questions the authors are
here so for later yeah okay and
essentially like uh so I want to present
you some so some nice application of
That So like um side Channel attacks in
crypto systems is a master thesis of of
Thomas venik uh and essentially like the
uh the interesting thing is you know
like uh Advanced encryption standards
AES right like it's actually like uh uh
it's it's a safe thing thing right so
like you have like some plane text and
some key right and essentially like
that's a encryption algorithm which
should like just like
uh like essentially encrypt your plane
text and essentially give you a cipher
and if you have the key essentially like
an invertible function you can like go
back to your Plaine text it's in
principle safe unless you execute it on
a physical device
which is kind of cynical because you
always uh uh execute it on a physical
device for example your bank card or
whatnot so essentially when you use a
physical device this physical device
will have some leakage like power
consumption time consumption electromag
magnetic emissions heat emissions so the
crypto folks never get tired to like uh
try new side channels so called so
artifacts of the of the physical device
which uh performs your algorithm and
essentially this artifacts contain
information about what you actually want
to in particular sensitive is the key
because if I get your key then I can
read all your future me messages and
this is surprisingly effective so here
is like essentially like a sort of
advanced encryption standard AES
essentially Works via rather simple
computations essentially like there's so
it works with this four times four crits
so like these are bites you would start
essentially like with um with your
message and like exort it with a key
right so like a uh with with yeah
essentially like with the key
then this is really just like permuting
States so right this may right so it's
just a permutation of your States
between 0 and 255 this this thing then
you would like actually have like this
shift rows here so like essentially the
whole thing just wants to have like an
invertible function but a complicated
function so that you can actually
scramble your information you have
essentially like something like a matrix
multiplication model to to and then uh
you again X or with the key and
essentially do this in 10 Rounds or so
and then essentially after that you have
completely scrambled your plain text and
the invertible function is determined by
the key that's essentially what's
happening so really it's just like a
bunch of computations which you can
actually describe in logic so here
essentially so like this is like the
actually the algorithm is repeated for
10 rounds but typically what people do
is like attack just the first stage of
that so here it goes in your your key
and your plane text yeah you have a
bunch of X ores this is like sub
scrambling your States essentially like
uh yeah then essentially here and now we
have this so-called mixed column uh
stage where you really just do a crazy X
or with all these inputs so like four
input bytes yielding uh four output
bytes the whole thing is invertible but
essentially like really just a scramble
function yeah and uh in all stages of
this uh computation of course your your
algorithm has like leakages yeah
electromagnetic leakages like indicated
with this green errors here and what you
can do is like if you have like the same
device at home in your Sellar you just
Square it with a lot of keys and and
plain text and you see you measure for
where so like for conditional on each of
these states here or each of these
variables you measure essentially like
you take a statistical pattern about
this leakages which essentially allow
you uh to come up with a statistical
model so if you have a new leakage you
can get actually a good guess about what
the state here is yeah essentially just
play a base rule yeah so like you you
have a likelihood a function for for
these leakages which essentially allows
you to give you a guess a probabilistic
guess about all these states
here right so like you measure this and
ENT also like at at various other
locations and essentially you have like
soft information about all these
intermitted variables you know how they
are related via logic essentially all
you want to do is like distill this
information propagated to what you want
to learn namely the
key and so like there's a
state-ofthe-art algorithm Sasa and they
are using so-called loopy belief
propagation on that so to infert the key
so like they assume so in this scenario
it's assumed okay you can actually see
the plain text and you want actually to
learn the key that you can actually uh
decrypt future messages yeah and you
have like the statistical models and
it's surprisingly effective it's
scaringly effective on the other hand so
like a a colleague of mine said well
still this is pointless because like the
biggest loophole is human stupidity like
but still since you can hack these
things uh relatively easy as with the
side General Texs so just uh to give you
a refresh about belief propagation or
loopy belief
propagation well essentially it's based
on a on a dis glassical graphical
description based on a factor graph of
of a unnormalized distribution right
like random variables you have like
factors like this means factor a is just
like a function of these two guys Factor
B is a function of these two guys FC is
like function of these two guys this
function only of this guy you multiply
these factors they are non- negative
which unnormalized distribution and
essentially I said marginalization is
what you want to do I compute the
partition function so the normalization
constant or like get a marginal and this
is essentially done by Distributing sums
and products essentially like pulling
that pushing that into your Factor cph
essentially like so like if you want to
have the margin of this guy and there is
like this sub Factor cph essentially do
uh if you have like the summation here
essentially it's just like a message
which get gets further propagated on a
high level that that's what happening
and this is an exact summation algorithm
if the factor graph is a tree but this
thing here is not a tree is a scary
loopy craft and essentially what people
do is like sending messages here like uh
in circles this has actually like no
real guarantees are like very weak
guarantees does it converge does it
converge to the true marginals you
actually don't really know yeah but you
hope for the best and it's like well if
you do that here essentially approximate
inference with message passing you can
actually really guess the the key
nicely so like the main idea is like now
use this circuit technology so like
essentially like this piece here is
actually just like a big chunk of logic
so like and the idea is like well let's
so like essenti it relates these four
input bytes with the four output bytes
so can we just like make a big uh tooth
table essentially represent it as a as
an STD so as a logical circuit and the
surprising thing is like well you have
like uh well 32 bytes so uh um um no so
like you have uh eight bytes so times uh
hold on 1 two 3 four eight 8 * 8 so like
64 bits and you have like logical
constraints all these X ores it was kind
of surprising that yeah you can actually
compile this this whole thing it's a few
it's a circuit of like a few thousand
notes or whatnot and now essentially
what we've done is like we have now all
these leakages so like here we have this
part four times here this plate notation
four times this stuff uh we have like
this output variables intermediate
variables where you have where you
measure the leakage and get like guesses
about these intermediate results and
they are now all tied with this huge
High dimensional Factor represented as
an STD so that the whole trick is by
just like lumping all this together we
have now essentially like a tree yeah
and we can actually do exact message
passing which in circuit uh uh language
means multiply this guesses about your
intermediate results multiply it with
the sdd and then just do exact inference
uh over the key so this was the
plan and uh yeah ultimately it worked
but first of all it did not really work
so essentially like you know uh you have
this relatively big circuit describing
what the central logic this mixed column
is yeah which is already pretty big and
now we have essentially like for each of
these guys eight you have like uh
distribution about 256 States and in
principle you just say well you just
take the product
uh and the product is um to so like
essentially you compile all these
distributions also in PD or like in in
in in circuits and multiply it into this
circuit so like to get like a big
distribution over
everything and now the the the thing is
now essentially you have like a product
of nine circuits which essentially blows
up so it's like quadratic roughly like a
worst case quadratic but if like growth
whenever you multiply but you multiply
nine times like this really blew up at
least on the on the hardware my master
student used so the the the trick was
essentially like to simplify like the
all these leakage distributions right so
like this bwise distributions here
essentially we had two ideas like let's
introduce like independences then you
get like smaller circuits uh this didn't
work too well and then very simple ideas
was uh that um each of these
distributions has pretty some Spar
structure so essentially many of these
values essentially are close to zero so
we just set them to zero so we just took
like the one minus Epsilon portion of
the probability set the rest to zero
renormalized and this yielded way
smaller circuits which you could
actually really uh multiply in and
actually do exact inference and the
thing is well this actually set at least
on this toy problem new state-ofthe-art
so essentially like this is really like
what crypto folks are doing saska based
on belief propagation and here yeah so
the the success rate essentially like is
measured you get some rankings like
whenever the keys among like the top
whatk ranking and you call it a success
it's it's measured in in some weird way
uh so long story short essentially by by
essentially approximating these uh
leakage distributions and doing exact
inference we actually were able to
outperform like this um this
state-of-the-art message passing based
uh inference uh using exact uh
distributions so we had to approximate
slightly but then performing exact
inference essentially like gave you
quite some improvement here
yeah
all right
so so uh yeah I also I recently started
a project uh on on on uh DNA storage so
essentially like using DNA to construct
a so-called structure and then
essentially like imprint uh imprint
information there essentially like a DNA
CD uh ZD compact dis anden like we you
have to use computer vision to it out
and then using some error correction
again some logic piece of logic the idea
is like really like to just incorporate
with this neuros symbolic circuit
approach directly the error correction
in your visual recognition system so
this is actually we haven't done this
yet but this is the plan yeah so not a
funky application of
circuits are there maybe questions about
this crypto side attack
or you say more about how is the sucess
of your
okay
um okay so like essentially yeah yeah
right so essentially while you have all
these leakages distributions well given
leakage what is the distribution of this
intermediate results you clue that all
together with the logic right so
propagate essenti information to the key
now get the distribution of a keys and
now you have essentially like most
likely key second likely key essentially
like you list up like them and you say
have a threshold something like a
threshold we say if it's among the top
10 uh right so then essentially like
your attacks are like you try the first
10 keys or so if it's if you have a hit
then it's a success otherwise not it's a
little bit more but roughly along these
lines I like have you actually guessed
uh among the top K candidates the
correct key roughly along these lines
yeah details in
the chosen Rand yeah so like the
Assumption here is that a prior they are
uniformly at random yeah so otherwise
you would the problem would be easier
right like yeah
yeah
okay so um another line of research is
uh uh We've recently started is like how
how to connect continuous generative
models with probabilistic circuits so to
motivate this so um well uh there are a
lot of generative models in in the
machine Learning Community you've
probably heard about guns generative
aell networks a encoders energy based
models normalizing flows uh Auto
regressive models and whatnot so all and
PCs uh and essentially all of them they
want to chieve the same thing they want
to model a distribution over data and I
said so what you want to do ultimately
with a probability distribution is
performing inference right so like you
want maybe samples you want density
evaluation marginals conditionals
moments maximization expectations what
whatnot and like the poor thing so where
really shine is that all these funky
mainstream generative models actually
they cannot do that right so like they
all fail at marginalizations and other
inference routines and PCs can actually
do that on the other hand they are way
more general or like way more flexible
typically and like more successful in
data fit yeah so like they produce nicer
samples produce higher likelihoods yeah
so essentially there's like a gap and
the Gap can be
explained VI the tractability
expressiveness LMA right so like PCS
have like stronger uh strong stronger
assumptions and therefore like you are
less flexible your hands are a little
bit tight right and essentially like you
have this tractability expressiveness
dilemma although I'm not really sure
where we really are in practice like
theoretically this is clear but in
practice I'm not really sure whether
this is like really the main source of
um why PCS are a little bit subar to
these other models another idea and this
is like actually linking to this
continuous generative model thing is all
these successful things like GS and V
they are essentially like so-called
continuous latent variable models and
the PCS are essentially like discrete
mixtures so and essentially it's like
kind of an intuition that this might
also play a role here so essentially a
discrete mixture is really just like a
convex combination of densities right so
like you can also interpret this as a
latent variable yes like a as a latent
discrete latent variable which has been
marginalized from the model typical
examples SC mixtures PCS they are and
typically tractable so you can actually
perform inference and all these nice
funky machine learning based models are
essentially like can be understood as
continuous mixtures so essentially you
have like a simple uh base distribution
prior distribution mixing distribution
which is typically something like a
white gaussian and you have like some
newon Network representing a conditional
over x given C so in V East you would
output like a simple gaussian which
those parameters depend highly non
linearly on on C I like this lat in code
in G essentially like the same uh flows
have also like the same idea but with
transformable with with invertible
transformations in the end essentially
what you do is like having this big
integral over C which makes the whole
thing highly intractable so like a high
dimensional integral is an computation
nightmare so all these models are like
essentially intractable but uh and this
is like actually like the the inside we
we wanted to follow they all connect the
latent code and uh X in a continuous way
right so like if you have a neural
network between X and maybe the
parameters of uh between Z and the
parameters of X or like the distribution
of the parameters of X or like in G
directly relating X and C via some
continuous transformation and it's kind
of uh you could think that this has to
do with like their generalization
properties and essentially why they work
better in
practice so essentially the motivation
here is like can we get both of best of
both worlds can we have like PCS now
also with latent with continuous latent
variables or so-call interal not and
really this was like the I guess like
really the main motivation of us like oh
we have Su notes we have product notes
we have distributions can we have
integrals and essentially what would
that even mean and essentially like the
the most natural thing here would be to
have like a continuous L variable in
your PC but we are fans of tractability
so can we still have like essenti
tractable inference right so that it
seems like to be in conflict because
High dimensional integrals are
hard except uh when they are not or like
when they are essentially so like
continuous latent variables models are
like this integral here if the latent
Dimension right if C is like just
onedimensional right then I have like a
one-dimensional integration problem well
you can just shoot at it with numerical
integration or like if you if C is like
sufficiently small then you can actually
still apply numerical integration Like
quadrature rules and essentially like
make this like morally tractable so to
speak Al what is interesting right so
like all these qu quad rules essentially
approximate this integral with a
weighted sum of this integrant so like
you pick like integration points and
like weights but essentially you replace
this integral with a sum and this also
like as a PC person you say it's a sum
so we're back in PC land right so
essentially interpreting numerical
integration schemes as again as a sum
node which is like in interesting right
so like if you have this continuous
variable model but now you approximate
it which again gives you a sum which
essentially means oh I have a new
network in here which is a weird way to
parameterize my my model but the actual
inference machine is brings me back to a
standard PC those parameters are
essentially given by this continuous
model here
essentially and yeah so
um essentially like yeah so that now two
papers like the first one was uh uh
let's have a continuous variable model
so like essentially using a PC so this
would be just a PC depending now on a
continuous variable with relatively low
Dimension uh and similar as in this
other funky machine learning based
models this is like again like a low
dimensional white gaus and prior and
essentially like this model here x given
C so the par is just determined as
follows like the parameters of the PC
are essentially governed by the the
parameters of the PC are governed by C
this lat and code via some neuron
Network yeah and uh yeah so used even
pretty simple PC structures like fully
factorized or like a simple tree but
which now depends like in a continuous
way on lat VAR
and was that kind of surprising that
even the simple structure actually uh
set new state-of-the-art like comparing
to the best standard PC and essentially
like these are like our methods and yeah
so like variations so like this is fully
factorized this is with this tree
structure and this is like well some
other heck or like other technique
essentially like setting new
state-ofthe-art on these 20 binary data
sets so uh we were talking about
benchmarks in PC land this is kind of
our benchmarks and they they are not
that great so like I call them sometimes
the 20 terriable data
sets Okay yeah so um Plus for
he very
good okay just lost context you talk
about continuous integration
right binary data set
not well well the latent variable is
continuous uh but the the x is the the
data is binary okay so you can
essentially yeah so essentially like
it's about the latent variables so so in
PCS normally the latent variables are
naturally discrete and like the the big
conjecture here and like we wanted to
play with integral nodes that was the
real reason but or can we have
continuous latent variables the leaves
are really not a problem you can use
discrete uh you can use discrete or like
leaves of discrete data or continuous
data the leaves are not a problem the
XIs you can pick whatever you want the
latent variables are essentially
naturally confined to discrete
hierarchies of discrete latent variables
now with continuous ones essentially
like a continuous latent variable over
discrete data yeah
yeah okay also like the samples look uh
nicer right so like uh right here so
like and essenti I think like the main
motivation for alaro was like to put
this in here because like these are
samples from the models I developed
which are really looking like kind of
shitty like so like this new continuous
variable models produce way nicer
samples and then essentially we recently
followed up uh right so like the first
ideas like this first idea was just like
having a PC both parameters are governed
by a small continuous latent variable
but what we really were striving for is
like really build that uh into the
structure uh in a more intimate way and
essentially like a recent follow-up work
with jaro Gala and Casio and Antonio and
the supervisor Eric for the supervisor
of jaro essentially we thought well can
we have can we do more can we have
essentially like something like a latent
tree over continuous variables and
essentially like they govern essentially
like these observables so having
essentially like a PC structure is now
essentially like a new kind language so
to speak essentially it's like using
standard PC language sums and products
but inter leaves like this integral
notes with the semantics so to speak
that you have like always a continuous
lat variable in here so whatever is
below depends on this datat and varable
essentially you have like message
passing essentially need to integrate
along the way so if this if if you use
like uh maybe gaus 10 factors here you
can actually do that like analytically
pretty similar in as in your work right
like doing like some stuff an analytic
but again here we used numerical
integration and if you're careful
essentially like you get essentially
again something like an inference
machine for this uh semic continuous PC
or like a p probabilistic integral
circuits ENT can again spawn it to back
to a a standard PC with a lot of su
nodes those parameters depend on these
continuous factors in between here yeah
yeah the parameter lower down depend on
all the don't you get another
dimensional well um so in the in the
paper we just submit so like now you
have like essentially have like a tree
structure so like you need to respect
this tree structure here this is uh so
like this lat varable only depends on
this one and this becomes independent of
of this one given this one so your B is
like like this independent structure
here which is not shown here so yeah so
I think we are not yet settled on how to
like represent this on a higher level
but essentially yeah we have like this
independent structure here
yeah you do high integrals I mean i' say
more car right um and in fact my my
students uh you know we got a reject at
some point and and the reviewer said you
should try Hamilton M car on this neural
net and we did it was annoyingly
effective M right so mention alternative
right you could just go
mcmc right right right yeah you can do
that you can essentially do a lot of
things you can do analytic you can like
do numerical integration you can do
sampling you can do variational you can
do all kind of inference scenarios true
I think uh one one motivation why we
want to do that essentially you know in
probabilistic machine learning
everybody's doing either sampling or
variational and if you ask well where
are the guarantees here there are
actually well good luck with coming up
with good guarantees with sampling and
uh variational they are essentially none
and it's not really easy in numerical
integration but at least if we get like
right so like the integration bins are
essentially like the number of some
nodes you spawn here right so like
essentially like you have this is our
model and you can essentially design how
how uh how fine grain your inference
machine is which which means you get
like more and more sum nodes here and at
least we have the theory if you if we
use enough then we get so like and in
principle can derive bounds it's not
easy depend on like these factors in
here and the lip shits conent whatnot
but in principle we can derive that in
in an easier way than with sampling like
one of our motivation that we can can
actually derive bounds here
yeah so uh in for the sake of time so
like Antonio really wanted me to show
this image so but I won't explain it for
the sake of time so yeah really it's a
yeah so these are integral nodes and
like yeah this is like our inference
machine based on numerical integration
like we get a lot of sums here these are
like the new networks we use between
latent variables these are the new
networks which we which choose latent
variables and observables and
essentially like we'll get an
approximate likelihood we use with train
with
adom okay yeah it's this is interesting
though so like uh essentially like
illustrating when you use like a
standard discrete PC right so like
essentially like this this dependency
between like latent variables typically
don't have uh so essentially the idea
here was like we can
so our inference machine essentially is
again like a standard PC we just like
give this free parameters and learn this
you get like this essentially no
structure if you have this continuous
factors you get essentially like this
nice dependency which is maybe
interpretable maybe not you have the
feeling that essentially like this
latent potentials here get essentially
like something like a interesting
structure and yeah again stateof the-art
essentially like here more or less uh so
if if if you're here so like these are
like standard PCS here is our stuff
essentially if you're here then our
stuff wins on a wide Benchmark of like
on on a big Benchmark mist and
variations
yeah right um yeah I think that's about
it so
[Applause]
thanks
continuous variables in PC seriously
yeah right let's take the questions to
the coffee
break